[Applause]
this was daniel ortega's fourth
consecutive swearing-in ceremony flanked
by his wife rosalio murillo his vice
president he vowed to improve conditions
in nicaragua the second poorest country
in the americas after haiti retro
we are here again with a clean slate to
build peace to assure that nicaraguans
have a dignified life to eradicate
poverty in this country with sovereignty
and freedom
the president of cuba and venezuela were
there and also delegations from iran
bolivia russia and china
but ortega was snubbed by almost
everyone else
november's presidential elections have
been dismissed as illegitimate by much
of the international community the
majority of ortega's competitors were
imprisoned so they could not run and
thousands of others have gone into exile
and legitimacy is not an issue
for ortega he managed to essentially
consummate
uh his uh
his uh his plan uh to establish
a full
and classic uh latin american
dictatorship in nicaragua
hours before the ceremony the european
union and the united states announced
new sanctions against high-ranking
military and communications officials as
well as members of the ortega family
but exiled opponent monica baltodano a
former sandinista commander who once
fought alongside ortega questions their
effectiveness
they demonstrate that the international
community realizes what's happening in
nicaragua and that's why it imposes
sanctions they have a moral effect a
kind of consolation but in practical
terms they'll have little impact
while ortega celebrated his latest
inauguration
some 170 political prisoners languished
in what human rights advocates describe
as cruel and inhumane conditions
one of them is
my husband is losing his memory and he's
in a deep depression after spending more
than 100 days in a punishment isolation
cell
he can't remember the names or faces of
our daughters
ortega made no mention of his
pre-election promised to initiate a
dialogue with his political opponents
that may explain why most nicaraguans
whom al jazeera consulted about the
inauguration
preferred to say nothing at all lucia
newman al jazeera